so let me ask you something if you take
something that's stupid
and you add something that's stupid
to it what do we call that stupid
squared
that'll work what go was stupid squared
it's not really adding it's multiplying
stupid by stupid that would be stupid
squared right let's get the formula
right here so here listen to this
this will blow you away I can't breathe
this is the dumbest thing okay if you
thought that student this is an article
if you thought that student loans were
just for students to go to school then
think again a recent survey has found
that one out of five 21 percent of
college students are using their student
loan proceeds to invest in Bitcoin
twenty one percent of college students
are borrowing money on a student loan to
invest in Bitcoin the Boston Globe did
this study that ladies and gentlemen is
stupid squared that is stupid times
stupid we are going into debt on a
student loan and investing it in Bitcoin
why yeah I'm gonna take my student loan
proceeds we're going to Vegas
we're playing roulette we're gonna play
blackjack in Vegas which back to
actually blackjack you probably have a
higher mathematical probability of
winning than with Bitcoin wow this blows
my mind so on so many levels this is
wrong number one
it's illegal yeah it's illegal when you
sign a student loan document do you
promise in the document to use the money
for school why is that hard it's illegal
to use your student loan money to buy a
house or invest in Bitcoin number two
it's immoral because you lied to get the
student loan money I'm borrowing the
money for school
I lied I'm going to put it into Bitcoin
and then number three it's ridiculously
stupid you're gonna lose the money and
guess what the student loan debt is
still gonna be there and then you're
gonna walk
and cry about how unfair your little
victim but life is unbelievable I mean
if it was five percent of students are
borrowing money on their student loan
and I'm investing in Bitcoin happy one
twenty one percent this is a substantial
level of stupid five college students
with student loan debt one of those
idiots put the money in Bitcoin oh my
god this is unbelievable I mean just
which you know it's like a game show
pick the idiot you know oh my gosh yeah
you're an idiot
absolutely ridiculous now if you want to
invest in Bitcoin I think it's dumb ok
Iying it's dumb I really do I mean
because I if you want to put money in
there though you because you
philosophically believe and the freedom
of currencies on the internet and all
this BS that some of you're in but
basically it comes down to you're trying
to get rich quick and you're investing
in a highly speculative unproven
financial product line currency
cryptocurrency and there's a high
probability you're gonna get bit in the
butt because of this you're most likely
gonna lose all your money now well
cryptocurrency eventually get its
footing and eventually turn into a
legitimate currency at some point yeah
probably you do invest in it your money
I don't tell you to invest in the I
rocky dine are either your money put
money in this stuff it's unbelievable
but let's just take stupid and set it
over to one side then let's go borrow
money on the student loan and let's just
call that stupid but one out of five one
out of five people they borrowed money
on a student loan invested the money
into a Bitcoin in the middle of a
student loan crisis if this isn't
films for ending the student loan
guarantee program I don't know what is
the government that's you and me we the
people are on the hook guaranteeing 1.3
trillion dollars in student loan debt
and one in five of these idiots is
putting their money in Bitcoin and you
and I guaranteed the loan we're stupid
Congress is stupid the Senate is stupid
those were Givens but oh my gosh we
elected these idiots and these idiots
continue to vote this thing this
guaranteed student loan program into
existence so that people go and get a
degree in a PhD in underwater
basket-weaving this is unbelievable and
they spend the balance of their money on
Bitcoin this is ridiculous
the absurdity of this is unfreaking
believable if the student loan crisis
was not enough to make you wake up and
go we the people don't need to be
guaranteeing one hundred and forty five
thousand dollar loan for an eighteen
year old who's never had a job
no banker in his right mind would make
this loan but you and I make this loan
every day it's called a student loan
program and oh god if you took away the
student loan program oh the little
people will not be able to get ahead the
people don't get ahead by student loan
debt there's no data that shows that and
by the way one in five of the little
people are putting the money in Bitcoin
you idiots good yes gracious this is
unbelievable
Adam Minsky Boston attorney specializing
in all things student loan related says
I would air to the side of it not being
a kosher thing to do legally but
regardless of that I don't think it's a
wise thing to do financially well thank
you Adam mark Cantor it's a student loan
expert there's what you want to be known
as bet his grandmother's proud if you
invest the student loans and
cryptocurrency and lose the money you
will still owe the student loans Wow
you make your living like I do with a
firm grasp on the obvious son
unbelievable yeah of course you still
owe the money
one in five let your Congressman know
you need to stop guaranteeing student
loans for cryptocurrency now to put
these idiots in jail how bad this is
it's unbelievable it's illegal it's
immoral and it's stupid squared this is
the Dave Ramsey show